pop
[Musique]
et
l'eau est nette et les basses dont
l'ouverture s'est vraiment gratuit
28 février 1982 il neige sur
saint-hippolyte dans le jura au
confluent du doubs et du dessous paul
perrin a plus de 70 ans il est retraité
jean michel radix militaire de carrière
à un peu plus de vàd la pierre mais
n'est pas encore sorti sa nature sont
contre tout neuf il est encore froide
près de 50 ans les séparent mais ils
sont unis par une passion commune la
pêche et demain c'est l'ouverture de la
truite leur technique aussi d'y faire le
jeune pêche au vairon mort l'ancien
préfère le ver de terre
[Musique]
bon alors la vente à de cette mouture
consiste à prendre un nom en gros
hameçons du numéro un mort ont de la
rigueur de longues tiges juillet sur
lequel je pose un morceau de condat
piano que je lis ligature habite du fil
de cuivre passer au préalable au papier
de verre légèrement de façon à en
enlever le vernis je prends ma page je
coupe mon fils je coupe mon morceau de
piano de mode de façon ce qui dépasse
d'environ un millimètre nbi de
millimètre de levier candidature terminé
jugé suspect suffisamment grosse je
soude bleus tout ce délire j'oppose de
la soudure pour boucher tous les les les
aspérités du fil de cuivre
je prends maalim jeu poli comme il faut
le corps de madame sont de façon à ce
qu'il n'y ait pas d'aspérités qui qui
abîme le vert lors du montage
la première opération consiste à
confectionner une barrette je tourne
autour d'un cloud gabarit ce qui me
donne exactement la dimension du trou de
mme barrette
quand elle a passé un savon ne collera
pas après le plus loin une fois que j'ai
savonner m'arrête je la sens entre
passes dans le trou
je la sens très bien voilà je m'écoutais
je cumule deux coups j'enlève le trop
plein je sors de ma monture je vais des
moules alors là on se brûle aussi je
prends le chiffon et je tire mon ex et
le mot tu ressors il n'y aurait pas de
savon ça collerait donc c'est l'intérêt
du savon sur la barre est bien sûr
encore on ne peut pas couler précis il
ya du monde et babula autour mais c'est
pas grave
or j'en étais bavure à la passe de
quatre coups de parce que je donne un
coup de lime pour fignoler
maintenant j'ai fait ma boucle après mon
étui petite boucle
vous voyez comme ça
maintenant je vais mettre cet homme sont
là que j'ai redressé c'est un homme sans
dommages même somme où je passe le lieu
de l'hameçon dans ma boucle j'ai la plus
écarter le lieu de 900 quand tu passes
dans la boucle
je redonne un coup de pince pour
resserrer mon oeil et voilà on monte le
terminal
lamentable cette monture et lorsqu'on a
fait travailler agression de la can le
verrouillage naturellement
je viens voir
[Applaudissements]
c'est michel comment vas tu qu'est ce
que tu fais avec ça on était bien je
vraiment ce qu environ pour l'ouverture
le médecin qui s'y seraient des sous
pour première catégorie la perche où la
pêche aux requins dollars mais j'essaie
bien commun oui mais tu apprendras on
n'a pas le droit de pêcher mais ma
bouteille si tu veux des vairons tu vas
en deuxième catégorie
tu mets ta bouteille temps problèmes
comme ça tous les internautes urbain
écoute jean pierre toucas cas pas faire
une histoire pour recaser tout de même
donc je sais que une carte
je passe pour aujourd'hui tu arrêtes et
tous leurs péchés toute la journée on
accorde un tout ramassé veron et puis je
commence la journée
à part ça ça va mais quand ce n'est pas
pour demain nous dénonçons ouverture
mais comme ce que m oui cela fait un
bond
haweij or ils sont prêts à mourir cette
année chez lui m e fermeté moyens c'est
vraiment génial sont quand même pas trop
villas sont pas nerveux les gars
venaient d'assister à l'opération de
pied tirage des verts c'est comme ça
qu'on obtient les meilleurs vers des
terres pour pêcher la truite à l'avertir
ce qu'on appelle le vert à tête noire
l'attend le terrain est propice
aujourd'hui c'est un peu difficile parce
que c'était gelé les verts s'enfoncent
mais en ces temps normal on arrive très
bien à sortir sain quantité de verre
qu'on a une journée de pêche et ses
meilleurs vert parce qu'il est naturel
il est dur la truck j'adore j'adore ça
vers là c'est son repas préféré
voilà disons le on peut pas comparer la
pêche ouvert à la pêche aux gérants tous
les deux sont bons tous les sens bon ça
dépend des os et des pros des
profondeurs d'eau ça dépend de pas mal
de trucs mais en général le verre est
toujours bon ah bon pêcheur ouvert dans
une rivière comme ici c'est sa pêche
toute l'année ce n'est pas le premier a
pas c'est pas comme la cuillère comme
les deux ou c'est pas de la
quincaillerie
à mon avis il ya mieux
et voici arrivés le jour de l'ouverture
l'ouverture qui est fixé immuablement au
1er mars dans les eaux franco suisse
quel que soit le jour de la semaine le
temps s'est remis au beau mais la
rivière reste basse
[Musique]
dès le lever du soleil des centaines de
pêcheurs des deux côtés de la frontière
se sont lancés dans une joute
halieutiques et parfois oratoire qui
n'exclut pas le folklore
[Musique]
un moment il ya 25 km de parcours le
parcours de vous moi c'est un très très
beau parcours c'est un très très beau
parcours qui part depuis le refrain on
traverse les gorges du thé seraient
pleines de roche et ça se poursuit
jusque jusque deux côtés de fui c'est un
petit pays au lieu dit avant que le
doubs le rendre complètement en suisse
alors à ce moment là il fait plus
frontières il est suisse les eaux
françaises font chez les petits suisses
[Musique]
en principe c'est bon non personne ne
prend rien du tout c'est pas bon cette
année l'année passée 5e meilleur où elle
est passée on ait dépêché cette émission
fait c'est l'enfant rappelle sa chute
fatale après moi j'ai mon billet je suis
mais n'ont rien mis les pieds dans la
boue
la petite ouais c'est ça toi parce que
d'habitude ici c'est un couac y ait
beaucoup d'unités ici en général non
mais t'as pas question pour l'ouverture
pour m
cette année ils ont mis des trucs j'en
ai un maximum de deux truites de vaincre
et 22 cm l on a omis quelques-unes de
taille c'est tout juste pour dire
car garder en place pour monter des
petites
l'ouverture c'est le gros folklore alors
sommes nous allons y les gars viennent
avec leurs femmes souvent ça se passe en
restant beat hockey staff et puis
patatras qui puis patata l'histoire
dormir doux son des rivières des
rivières courant des rivières calcaire
et pour pêcher la truite pour pêcher
londres les chiffres font connaître la
pêche ça n'a rien à voir avec les
rivières folklorique de normandie où on
met des truites d'élevage toutes les
fêtes du comprendrait qu'un paquet
caucase
[Musique]
j'enfile mon verre jusqu'où lui à
l'hallali dalle 10 ans demandé suivant
la grandeur du verre pour avoir su mieux
que tu manques on en laisse trois ou
quatre centimètres ou cinq et sept
petites tiges de deux cordes à piano
guinée passe empêche mon verre de
glisser et sur l'action de pêche
pour le matériel chacun point un petit
peu ce qui lui convient chantal du
matériel sophistiqué bois fut canafe
l'intérieur c'est celle que je préfère
parce que ça me permet de passer ma
limite à des endroits touffu ou à une
grande bannière de 3 4 mètres ne peut
pas aller au repreneur puisse laisser
glisser mon fil du temps pour aller
chercher sous les racines c'est un peu
une bestiole quelconque moulinet le
mobile est ce qu'on peut mettre en
molina tambour fixe on peut mettre un
moulinet toute ordinaires uniquement
pour avoir une règle ne une réserve de
fil ça le moulinet joué aucun rôle dans
ce nous réserve de flip c'est tout c'est
pas important en avant sans plomber nuit
comme ça j'ai pas de planquer raccroche
dans les âmes qui rapproche à droite
avenue mont vert savoir tout seul au
fond de l'eau
nous verrons la voix basse que il a
déchiré bien celui là voilà je le fais
tu l'histoire en aiguille je passe mon
aiguille dans le film
ensuite j'ai passé les grilles d'un goal
du ver ans comme ça ça ressort à l'anus
ça voilà je passe mon trip dans fils
benoît kg bien trois tours plaques se
tire un petit coup
coupe
[Applaudissements]
au fil d'aventurés dans la gueule du
lion avec le crochet je vais clou de la
tête comme ça confie le triple voilà de
rentrée
[Applaudissements]
y a pas un qui monte du rallye même pas
des clubs français en ont rendu compte
de la 9 e coupé chez moi du peu péché
mais non mais l'été on te plus qu'à ce
moment tu as dû à queue devant la
chaussée - si tu en as tu es chez toi
partout tu sais mon transfert chez les
garçons la chaîne suisse pour menacer
médias que de telles furent habitués
c'est mon fils sur cette approche est
rien on m'a battue commence à faire
chien qui a dû au dessus faudra-t-il
edouard français aurait pu prendre la
meilleure que les riders t'es pas chez
toi ici d'ouvrir arriva et la douzième
fois même si c'est en partie dû au prix
qu'on pêche garcia l'a décroché relève
son chapeau [ __ ] terry wey
[Rires]
il ya des moments vraiment où la lutte
avec un poisson et j 7 au mérite si on
peut dire si cette phobie l'autre parce
que cette voie vraiment un beau poisson
qui comme moi étaient pas monter gros
butin bon poisson google doit faire
pourquoi alors c'est là qu'il faut être
calme patient et puis lui telus telus t
il
là c'est un très bon coin bien toujours
empêcher un petit renouveau sous la
chute normalement il y en avoir une
lancée sous la chaux-de-fonds
l'inventeur de la monture sur un fond
comme ça par exemple de galets c'est bon
on peut lancer le verront comme ça et
laisser dériver le verrons en roulant
sur le fond ça tout en contrôlant le
verrons la paix comme on pêche ouvert
est important c'est de sentir le biberon
but de la gagne ça c'est très important
mais là elles n'ont pas faim apparemment
dans l'accord une ratée
oh j'aime bien qu'ils l'aient
gouvernement j'aime bien qu'un peu de
soleil parce que d'une foire qui permet
de voir le verrons parce que je pêche
beaucoup à vue et d'autres ports ça
permet aux truites de sentir un peu ici
parce que par temps couvert des fois
elles restent classées sous les cailloux
ça c'est très con
on a un caillou gros caillou est juste
derrière eux un trou le trou profonde
ça nous fait un boom ou alors
normalement il devrait y avoir vu nos
rangs postes de chasse se lancer comme
ça voilà dans son bouillon
je ramène tout doucement je laisse
couler un peu ramène un peu
ah ça y est prenez une la touche est
patent d'affaires y est très bien
ah les belles 1 est pas mal
et pas mal
ah et par un courant là
en fait d'avoir dit publiquement
elle est belle elle est raillée bel la
rivière ses doigts
hop
ouais
à se défend bien
à l prochain
alors il va
celle là je la prends épouse est au
mieux
[Applaudissements]
ah oui j'oubliais
les papillons voilà les amis et les
saveurs casta contre web à cette
angoisse et une petite folie à briguer
ce changement fuc schiste à cette bo
fait du fric autre nom moyenne de 34
bilan enfin c'est ce que tupperware
si on n'est plus une pro vilaine environ
2 400 grammes alors j'ai eu des attaques
sans arrêt les des trucs qui sentait
sous les pires l'ancien blue gène sont
sous les cailloux une chanson de 20 de
croisière bouchons à chercher ici on a
eu froid ce matin
or ils ont elles prennent seuls qu'elle
a été chercher un peu le soleil
c'est ce qu'il faudrait c'est que l'eau
montait un peu ah oui les bars basse
pour une ouverture et les vrais membres
à ce juge propos si tu as plus de force
au val travaille bien et save moi je
suis meilleur pour le voir que pour le
débouché à l'eau après ça je n'ai jamais
douté un sens je n'ai jamais douté on
passait pour un livre non j'ai pas dit
ça
jean michel tu l'as vu non je n'ai pas
vu chez projet passé
[Applaudissements]
soit à peine 7
c'est joli
mais ne compterait pas parce que on le
voit elle est prise au bord
elle est prise depuis le bord des lèvres
c'est un peu dans bones aux demandes
marquent pas pour toi
c'est un tweet communes parfois de la
truite fario dont celle ci a une
particularité c'est qu'elle éveillé je
pense que c'est dû au fond
au fond de la rivière
[Applaudissements]
à noter chez les pirates et c'est
nouveau ça marche on est tous les genres
lieu tous les ans à tous les coups c'est
pareil il y dix noms seraient plus de l
allée belgium attendez je dis non et
comme avec un peu prendre deux fruits
comme ça qu'un cent mille huit cents us
à pour mimi le à peu près partie l'autre
poids lorsqu'elle fait trois livres tu
vois ça fait progresser des eaux
résiduelles qu'on peut a été tondue
s'est révélé lurette que l'afrique a
besoin l'offre et philippe déjean
janiver que ça se passe tu sais comment
ça se passe la faillite et je vais
t'expliquer c'est tout
ça se passe en hollande décembre une
désaffection
la femelle arrive sur un fond de
graviers de petits gravi assez simples
qu'elles creusent un lit dans le fond
avec son ventre les gens des contorsions
qu'elle dépose chez eux et le mal à rire
il est postale et ans sur les haies des
milliards de spermatozoïdes en chacun
tient il ya un tout petit trou et le
spermatozoïde rendement dans l'oeuf et
love se referme quelques minutes après à
ce moment là le vent a commencé à mûrir
il ya d'abord deux petits points noirs
qui apparaissent on voit très très bien
lieu c'est les yeux way et il arrive un
moment où l'offre est prêt à éclore
et c'est là que qui sur la première on
est que ce qu'ils y voient là le vin
sort les tout petits du rhin mm et demi
d'autres petits points noirs qui sont
les yeux une toute petite queue puis un
gros gros ventre c'est là c'est la
vésicule c'est ce qui va être la réserve
de nourriture de la petite de la petite
truite pendant les premiers moments de
sa vie où elle passe à s'alimenter tout
seul dans la rivière et puis petit à
petit à petit cette musique il va se
résorber et les alevins la prendre
l'alluré d'un vrai poisson serait bien
qu'on va voir apparaître épique
nageoires puis ça va s'allonger ça va
devenir
joli petit poisson alors il ya beaucoup
d'eux qu'ils sont pendus malheureusement
il n'arrive pas tous à maturité sur sur
1000 qui sont conduits va peut-être
arriver seulement quelques dizaines de
truites au non non non non c'est non
parce que enfin heureusement et
malheureusement si si tous les yeux
arrivent à maturité il y aurait trop de
poissons dans la rivière
quand j'arrive au bord de l'ariège je
suis plus le même homme
je me sens dans la nature j'oublie tout
je pense qu'à une chose la pêche vous
confisquer au calme afin de couper le
groupe et d'un an parce qu'à ce moment
là si je vais à la pêche je suis
européen
albert ii oc la moitié de ma vie rires
l'hiver je bricole des articles de pêche
parce que j'attends avec impatience
l'ouverture pour les buts rennais au
bord de l'eau
[Musique]
bon on va pas en jeu pour aller à la
pêche des jeunes j'irai plus c'est si tu
as une pub très laid au bord de l'eau
alors là c'est la fin de tout petit jeu
fédérer dans l'opus cependant on sait
jamais
qu'est ce qu'on sait
[Musique]